- Hey guys, it's Justine,
and today we are checking out
two things that are not even out yet.
So sit down, get hyped.
We have two prototypes of
these mobile laptop monitors
by Mobile Pixels.
I'm gonna put a link in the description
if you wanna check out their Kickstarter
and get all of the information about them.
But I'm really excited about this
because these new versions
are smaller, thinner, lighter,
and basically all around better
than the previous versions.
Now, I was so inspired
by kind of their story of creating these.
They've had several very
successful Kickstarters.
And now with the announcement
and launch of these,
it's sort of the perfect time
because everyone is still
kind of working from home
and I feel like that's gonna
be kind of transitioning
into the next year.
And a lot of people have laptops,
but being able to have an external monitor
or an extra screen is something
that not everybody has
the luxury of having,
but with this, this is at
a really great price point
and it just attaches
right onto your laptop
and it kind of gives you
that flexibility of using it
when you want it and not using
it when you don't want it.
Thank you to Mobile Pixels
for sponsoring this video
and getting me these two
prototypes to check out
to show to you guys.
So, let's open these up
and then I'll show you guys
in comparison to the previous
versions, what's new?
What's cool?
And we're gonna test it out.
Also did I mention?
I know I didn't mention because
I just started the video.
You can actually connect
your Nintendo Switch
to one of these as well.
I'm sold.
(scissors snipping)
(upbeat music)
Whoa, okay, it's unboxed.
Whoa, whoa, look at you.
Whoa, okay, that's cool,
that's pretty cool.
Okay, let's open up the Plus.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, that's cool.
So it looks like these just actually stick
to the back of the laptop, like that's it.
Okay, okay, cool.
So what's cool is these
monitors are powered by USB-C
so not only is it powered
by it, but that is
how you'll actually be
receiving the signal.
They do have a little converter here.
So if you don't have USB-C,
you'll be able to use
just regular USB 3.0,
and you'll be good to go.
I just wanna set this
up to my computer now.
Where are you?
They did say that this
will work on laptops
from around 13 inch to
about 15 and a half.
It does work on windows and Mac as well.
So we're gonna test out
the light version first.
I am very excited about the plus version
because this one also allows you
to connect to Android phone.
It has auto rotation
and you can connect it
to your Nintendo switch.
Let's try this one out first to get a feel
for how this thing works.
To the screen on here
is 12 and a half inches.
So it looks like we just attach
these little magnetic pucks
to the back of our computer.
We're good to go.
So we take off this adhesive.
So now we're gonna flip this over.
Cautious, I'm nervous.
I think we're ready.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, alright, it's on, it's on.
I did it
I get it.
That all makes sense.
So you basically, you're
just pulling this out
and then the whole thing
just slides like that.
This is cool.
I used to work at coffee shops a lot.
Like I would take my laptop.
I wish the coffee shops were
open because this would be me.
Look like I would be so cool.
(keyboard clicking)
Like people would always
come up to me, say,
"What are you working on?
"What are you doing over there?"
I'd make a lot of friends in this way.
I don't make friends now
because it's COVID times.
So the magnets on the
back are actually sliding
and it's allowing this
to come all the way out.
And because it's magnetic,
like we just go like this.
That's it.
Oh, this is cool.
This is cool.
Let's plug it in and try it.
I actually think I want my
monitor come out this side.
It makes it so easy, it's just magnetic.
And these are what is allowing
it to slide in and out.
Look, look.
I have a whole side desktop now.
Hold on a second.
This also flips all the
way around like this.
So if I wanted to show you something.
Look, okay, let me put a picture.
There you go.
And now, if I wanna get back
to my own content, I can.
It's also kind of cool
because I could use this
as like a little monitor to the side,
like it doesn't actually have to be on.
I just love that I can just
take this off and on so easily.
Oh man, let's test out
the Pro version now.
So I liked that this has
two additional USB-C ports
which is nice for something
like the MacBook Pro 13 inch
because it only has two ports as is
so you are giving up
one port for the monitor
and then you're gonna
need to charge obviously
so that doesn't leave you
with a lot of port options.
The Pro version is also bigger.
And since we already have
these magnets set up,
we shouldn't have to do any switching.
Okay, let's pop on this Plus,
see what this looks like.
It fits perfectly, right
over the top of the magnets
that I already had on with the light.
Does have a really cool
Kickstand accessory,
which I don't currently have
but that's also on the
Kickstarter, Kickstand Kickstarter.
It also has pass through charging
so if you want to plug this
in to charge your computer,
that also works.
I really like this black color.
It's a kind of like a
rushed aluminum type look.
This has a nice matte black.
And the buttons on the side,
much like the light version.
This is how you'll adjust the brightness
of the monitor itself.
Like I'm ready to do business.
(keyboard clicking)
Okay, this is actually pretty cool.
I got a picture of me and Maddie there.
Probably, you know, if I was working,
I would have something open
here maybe some extra footage,
some graphics, maybe the timeline,
or I can have this as
like a preview browser
or I could just be watching YouTube videos
while I'm working on an Excel spreadsheet
or a pages document or buying Bitcoin.
Also don't forget, this comes off, okay.
At my desk, when I'm normally
working on my Mac Pro,
I actually have one
monitor set up vertical,
and the other one just
regular horizontal like this.
And that's mostly
because I like to be able
to have a full screen
of all of my thumbnails,
or if I'm searching through footage,
this just seems like a
much easier way for me
to kind of organize it.
I'm basically replicating my desk set up
(keyboard clicking)
but on the go.
So to show you guys a
quick little comparison
between the new versions
and the previous older ones,
what's really great about the new ones
is you don't have to install
any additional drivers.
Everything just automatically works.
And these ones are so much lighter
than the previous versions.
It's significant.
The bezels on the newer
ones are so much smaller
so you're actually able
to get a smaller screen
but with a larger screen real estate
because of these smaller bezels.
I do really like the
newer magnet placement
because they're like
these tiny little circles
whereas the older ones
have these rectangles
and this doesn't actually slide.
This gives you a lot more flexibility
depending upon what size laptop you have.
(gentle music)
So setting up the Nintendo
switch is actually very easy.
So you plug in the original
Nintendo switch charger
and then plug in your Nintendo
switch using the USB-C cable.
Like I didn't even know that
this is something that I needed
until now I have it.
How did I live without it?
Okay, I'm still wearing
my Christmas outfit
and my hair is a mess because
I haven't played the game
in so long.
I'm wearing a happy new year hat.
I probably have cockroaches in my house.
Look at there it is, cockroach.
Get him, get him, get
him, get him, get him,
get him, get him, get
him, get him, squish.
Well, thank you guys so much for watching.
I will put a link in the description
if you wanna get more information
about both of these mobile monitors.
This is really cool to get
a chance to check these
out before they're even released.
So if you guys want more information,
again, link in the description,
and I will see you guys in the next video.
(upbeat music)